I'm sure this is a meeting of people who
say they're members of what they call
the largest self-defense group in
Burkina Faso armed with hunting guns and
other homemade weapons the self-styled
vigilantes are meeting in the country's
southern district of Baazigar to discuss
security in the area and what they say
are new strategies to keep people safe
this is their leader he says a group has
members across the country you know to
me we're not civil servants we're a
group of farmers herd as traders women
we provide security and advise our
people on good investments if people
want to reward us we take the money for
our logistics
they call themselves Kabul or Bush dad's
in the local moral language they came to
prominence in 2015 when government
security collapsed after the toppling of
former president Blaise Compaore who had
ruled for 27 years
to this day such so-called vigilantes
continued to fill the power vacuum
lelou computer is in order dugu like
many big towns we have police military
private security but in rural areas
there's nothing so the people see the
group as a savior in the village of
Rossum can't be imago ali and his unit
take us to the local markets he says
those like him who wear grey uniform are
Special Forces whose work is to arrest
suspects and investigate crime I joined
a group because my only Danka was Toulon
and police couldn't help me find it then
my ship was stolen and I said enough is
enough
when you come to small village centers
like this one people will tell you that
the group has helped the number of
highway robberies and petty thefts has
gone down but the collierville have also
been accused of human rights abuses
their justice is instant when you steal
a phone an egg or livestock you pay back
three times the cost and face public
humiliation to what people fear the most
is shame we tie them up to embarr
so that they don't do it again and to
deter others tell me which is a more
serious violation of Human Rights
killing someone and stealing property or
our justice system they're not formally
recognized by the government and don't
trust security forces it's an uneasy
relationship the interior ministry fails
to respond to Al Jazeera's request for
an interview but this meant talents
until everyone in the villages feel safe
the call WAGO is not going anywhere
Katherine SOI al Jazeera bazooka south
and Burkina Faso